we are very well covered from the
standpoint of bravery and talent we have
tremendous people there representing us
from the Coast Guard to FEMA to
everybody else
I've spoken to Governor Scott on
numerous occasions and they likewise are
very well prepared to the people of
Florida we just want you to protect
yourselves be very very vigilant and
careful again the governor is working
very hard FEMA the Coast Guard all of
our people are very well prepared that
was President Trump earlier today
assuring the people of Florida that the
government is as prepared as possible
for hurricane Irma this of course could
deliver a catastrophic strike on this
state now to give you a better idea just
how dangerous and destructive this storm
is and could be let's take a look at a
couple of headlines USA Today hurricane
Irma has the potential of affecting
every major city in the state of Florida
the new york post hurricane Irma is the
size of Texas
the Miami Herald to South Florida
nuclear power plants Lyon Irma's paths
are they ready and the Washington Post
US military preparations for hurricane
Irma now include four Navy ships and
thousands of troops and the daily beast
hurricane Irma look at this is stronger
than all of 2017 s other eight Atlantic
storms combined pretty scary joining us
now on the phone is the mayor of Key
West Florida Kraig cases with us first
of all mr. mayor thank you for being
with us you're in a direct path here and
as the governor mentioned earlier in the
program you only have bridges in and out
of your area and that means it is
evacuation time for everybody correct
yeah correct that is there's about 40
bridges that connect Key West to the
mainland and all the Florida Keys so
that being said a lot of opportunity for
one to get damaged and cuddle hole or
supplies returning or evacuation so
that's why we start evacuating early and
it's continuing through the day and
tomorrow okay really important when did
you start
the evacuation and how soon do you
believe that this enormous task it will
be accomplished well we started
terrorists in Wednesday morning and then
residence Thursday morning and which
goes on through tomorrow that we run in
our bus services tomorrow started at
noon today all of our buses of shuttling
a residents up to Miami to our shelter
which as you just talked about before is
very difficult on us because the
hurricane could go into Miami also but
it's much higher R and then down here in
the key so it still will be a safe area
but not absolutely perfect scenario
definitely mr. mayor are there any
people resisting the evacuation sir I've
been here in my whole life
fourth-generation and this is the first
time that so many people have evacuated
they are definitely heeding the warnings
they seen the power of this storm coming
across there they know what the 35 storm
did to the Florida Keys so people are
taking this very very serious all right
good job sir and I thought some prayers
are with you and of course all our
friends in the keys thank you for being
with us